walking up to this video playing by 2
which beta which from from Sweden see em
yes min beta which village okay let's
see the Scotch okay check playing my
tried and tested we should be for check
line I wanted to discard this quite a
number of times but at the end i keep
layered 3g for really this is not there
is Bishop e3 Bishop b6 Quincy for Quincy
for years is new to me okay let's see
how ever take it I mean this is
certainly okay at 94 I mean we should
deform take some I'm many interesting
ways to play okay let's start let's
start with this I mean it's probably
everything's probably good but it's not
not so sure what I what I should
actually play night Queen g7 so let's
consider rook g8 go into age six and
then I can take on diff I mean I could
have got everything developed and why
it's got nothing out it's really weird
okay and now I was thinking just night
takes care just night XD form Queen age
694 see for Bishop define threatening on
e for threatening 94 admission f 2 and 2
quite a lot
sure and it takes on c6 that would help
and I can also consider to knock on
let's play that not with any time on
that that is simply a good a good way to
play not even material down I wonder
maybe okay he even allow us last night
g43 okay 94 can also play 94 94 queen
age seven maybe nightly [ __ ] when
there's some days the rook hanging and
the porn hanging I can also just take on
g2 I mean there is really not clear if
there is something I come on why not
really don't see no reason not to take
it and now we'll bishop f2 or the
risking of one that's a bit that's
questionable really if this is so great
very Queen to e7 get the get the Queen
involved I take on e form
okay yeah maybe maybe this Queenie 7 was
a bit bit too lame that was a bit too
lame actually but not sure I don't think
I should take it what it would really
help him two coordinators ruin his
somewhat strangely plays pieces but
Queenie three I think now the screener
for probably coming now this was my idea
Bishop g4 is the the point Saudi five or
d6d five is more forceful Bishop defies
of course the threat d5 night eggs
yeah that's that's very good actually I
think only issue is that of course it it
costs time on the clock this is a
somewhat maximal istic approach okay I
thought that this should win now win the
queen or wind material some some in some
way or another yeah that's between
before also check white resigns he had a
sacred crunchy fries I think just not
not playable check so he probably
confused lines here I'm what there is
this Bishop e3 after which there is a
threat so I'll go here and then Queen
you for that actually am a known known
line which amongst others have has been
played by Kasparov and in a red rapid
game in the and sometimes years ago um
it's not that great actually but it's a
valid line um there is Queen f6 which
was always the move that I had looked at
when I studied this this opening but
recently they even found out that black
had played this year and sacrifice and
then I'm not sure she's 6 or d5 it's
very dangerous for white because he
loses so much time Queen G however here
looks really weird to probably maybe I
even had something better but it looks
really good now and so there's this idea
with noisy form and I'm just I have
three pieces developed the rope
and the two- and joe says no
compensation for that Queenie seven now
okay when she too is also good oh I
could actually this is this was a bit
stupid yeah so as I was forgetting that
I can go here actually winning a temple
then this is probably simply the best
line as it completely destroys white
skin formation okay so but this this
seems to be quite good t5s winning a so
this wasn't technically bad by me this
sir spotted this yeah there's no way to
save why no this is also check not
really an improvement and I can go here
which is also losing the house yeah what
Queen g4 was probably somewhat somewhat
like a mouse lip no one just confuse the
lines alright thanks for watching